we've had months of extreme weather but
prepare
for stark warnings that what seems
incredible now
may become normal in the future
the un's ipcc report will assess our
planet's current climate and use
groundbreaking modelling
to predict what's ahead we expect
projections of hotter days
making things like wildfires more
frequent in places you might expect them
but also in those you wouldn't this
was west yorkshire in 2019
this bit of the mall was really badly
damaged by a fire and there's still some
damage that lurks
lurks below if we have these fire events
longer term they dry the moors out and
the drier they are the more likely they
are to catch fire again so we get into
this sort of cyclical nature
and if fires here become more frequent
it will lead to floods
we had some some heavy rain about an
hour ago and already all the streams
have come up really quickly
it can sort of hold back the same amount
of water that it used to do
the ipcc reports are the most
significant reports in climate science
the previous one formed the backbone of
the historic paris climate agreement in
2015 which saw wild governments come
together
and pledge to limit global warming to
ideally
1.5 degrees celsius so
what can this new report do published
just months ahead of the u.n climate
conference in glasgow
for many millions monday's report will
provide the cold hard data behind the
reality they are already living
in june we traveled to bangladesh and
saw the impact of rising sea levels
and intensifying extreme weather like
cyclones
foreign
previous ipcc reports established the
link between global warming and human
activity
expect more on that in the report and
that may sound
bleak but really it brings hope that the
worst of a crisis
created by humankind can be avoided
if action is taken catherine of autopsy
sky news